[Music]
the first night that Katie Asia and I
all met each other was in New York I had
met Isha before because we tested
together but Katie I hadn't met I first
met Megan at the last audition I had for
the bolo type Hey
and I knew straight away that I loved
her so much what do I do
first of all you're gonna need to choke
cuz Lauren can smell your fear Katy
messaged me on Twitter I asked the
executive producer if I could have their
contacts and when he was taking too long
I actually found them on social media
and reached out to them she reached out
to me was like I'm so excited
we're together you want to come to New
York my boyfriend's playing a show and
so we all went to the concert together I
just remember being in Katie's hotel
room with her before Asia got there and
we were just getting ready and peeing in
front of each other like we had been
best friends already for years and right
away we did that crazy basic girl dance
where we all kind of like jumped around
in the elevator we just had a really fun
night of music and going out to bars in
New York and kind of trying to cultivate
that New York experience that us girls
would have and kind of inspire our
journey into the first episode two long
and prosperous careers at Scarlett it's
crazy that first night it felt like we
had known each other forever
we just tapped into a little bit of
magic
[Music]